what's going on guys this is Rob and the
Thor love and thunder teaser trailer
just dropped which looks really good uh
and here's everything we spotted and
probably some stuff that you missed so
in the opening scene when Thor is
running and it shows him as a kid and
then presumably a teenager and then his
older self probably somewhere around the
time that he ends up becoming a part of
the Avengers or before he's banished
that this is a reference most likely
probably a throwback more than anything
else to the Thor God of Thunder
storyline this idea that Thor actually
fought Gore the god butcher at three
different points in his life the first
time is when he's really really young
the second time is in the modern era and
the third time is when he's really
really old something else that we
noticed is the middle version of Thor or
the teenage one I guess is wearing his
classic comic costume from the old
journey into mystery Comics which is
really really cool the next thing of
course is that Thor symbolically buries
his superhero Side by literally burying
yarn Bjorn now now this is most likely
this whole discussion about him trying
to find some measure of inner peace and
walking away from his violent side and
trying to be a pacifist it probably
won't last very long so the next thing
is in the scene where he's exercising
the hat that he's wearing actually has
the original Avengers logo from the old
school Avengers Comics like the original
Avengers Comics I'm pretty sure this is
the same hat he was wearing when he
first saw him as fat Thor in Avengers
end game I loved fat Thor I always
thought he was cool right he'd look like
The Big Lebowski right the the Thor
abides anybody who gets that reference
now the next thing is the giant skeleton
and this is a source of contention
because I'm not 100 sure what the
skeleton is initially we thought it was
e tree but then we realized Eatery
didn't die so basically it's maybe the
body of a dwarf it looks like it's
underground or something like that maybe
it's inside a dabalier it would make
sense that everything going on with Thor
with him basically trying to make make
amends or to basically leave his violent
World Behind he may be going by and
making some stops at places he's been to
before nadavalier may very well be one
of those it could also just be a random
skeleton or it could possibly be the
body of somebody that Gore had already
killed but it had happened a long time
ago it would seem that if that's the
case Thor wouldn't necessarily exercise
in it like okay while I'm trying to
track down this guy Thor who's killing
all these Gods might as well make them
gains it doesn't really make a whole lot
of sense
that that's something Thor would do so
it looks like he's maybe retreading or
it's possible this is somewhere deep
within the Earth and he's basically
using it as a place to kind of train and
get away from everything not 100 sure
now one of the things to notice is in
the trailer Thor does have Stormbreaker
in the scene when he walks away from the
guardians but the surroundings look very
similar to the place where he's
meditating in the beginning of the
trailer indicating this is the scene
where he actually released the planet
where he leaves mjolnir behind not 100
sure sure but that may very well be the
case another thing that we notice is
when Thor is gracefully casting off his
cloak and he throws it on to Star-Lord
which looks amazing uh it looks like
he's wearing Peter Quill's jacket from
guardians one am I wrong it looks like
he tore the sleeves off and he's wearing
the jacket now which looks amazing I
absolutely love that uh another thing
here is that new Asgard still exists now
unlike in Marvel Comics new Asgard looks
like it's still in Norway uh it's not
really in Broxton Oklahoma the reason
why that matters those of you guys who
never really were part of the Thor
Mythos at all after the events of Thor
disassembled basically the death of Thor
essentially it's like Ragnarok and all
that kind of stuff in Marvel Comics that
Thor eventually came back and when he
did because the events of Ragnarok had
led to what was believed to be the death
of all the asgardians that Thor having
returned basically rebuilt Asgard in
Broxton Oklahoma that took place during
uh the Thor run of a guy named J Michael
strzinski and then after that Thor went
on a quest to basically find the
asgardians whose Spirits had inhabited
the bodies of mortal men and women Thors
had to wake them up the first person he
found was Heimdall because Heimdall
would be able to tell him where
everybody else was and so following that
he starts going through and waking up
various as Guardians and so on and so
forth until he eventually comes across
Bohr who
threw a weird series of mechanations had
basically uh had his essence or Spirit
stuck by Loki and then when boar showed
up Thor had to fight him Thor had to
kill boar and because Thor had
technically killed an Asgardian he was
banned from Asgard so that was
interesting that lasted until Siege when
Green Goblin decided to launch a
campaign to conquer Asgard didn't quite
work nonetheless we've gone on a little
bit of attention
some really cool things happen in the
Thor's storyline like fear itself when
everybody gets a hammer that was amazing
uh but the important thing here probably
the single most important thing in this
whole trailer we get to see the goats
we get to see Thor's goats and I'm so
excited about this tooth gnasher and
tooth grinder I love these guys there's
an amazing there's an absolutely amazing
moment in uh uncanny Avengers by I think
Rick remender where Thor fights the
villain apocalypse before he was able to
lift mjolnir otherwise he would just
beat the crap out of apocalypse and so
what he does the ax that you see in uh
in the movies right the action he has
that's yarn Bjorn so that act was
initially just an accident was there at
least it looks like it maybe it's just
maybe it really is Stormbreaker I always
assumed it was yarnbjorn I always
figured that was the case it's the only
other weapon that Thor ever uses aside
from mjolnir and the reason why is
because apocalypse is a villain who uses
Celestial technology so he's very
difficult to kill and what Thor ended up
doing was basically doing a handful of
different things that involved a
combination of King and Loki and
basically ended up imbuing yarn Bjorn
with the energy to destroy Celestial
technology or Celestial armor so he
basically ended up attacking apocalypse
and ultimately defeated him but during
their first outing their first conflict
went through a realized he couldn't win
he summoned his goats and basically took
off on the Chariot and so literally
apocalypse is like okay
I'm fighting this guy and he literally
just wrote off
on a chariot pulled by goats
that's weird
but it's a it's a really really funny
little moment that goes on there um
however again in the comics uh tooth
grinder and tooth Masher actually end up
pulling a chariot instead of a boat but
the reason why it's a boat is most
likely because of where new Asgard is
located uh in the comics new Asgard or
Asgard itself is destroyed but it's
rebuilt by Iron Man and is called
asgardia and it actually orbits Saturn
so of course there's some big changes
that are going on here in the MCU
regarding the the concept of like new
Asgard and all that kind of stuff uh but
the cool thing here is that tooth
gnasher and tooth grinder man these guys
are legit uh they're amazing
I might make a video on Comics explained
like like Thor's goats explain I might
do that just just to see if that video
even does well I don't know I feel like
it'll just do insanely well because
people are just like the goats we would
have learned about the goats but
nonetheless it's cool to see them here I
wouldn't be surprised if they have some
moments over the course of the film
where like they kind of save Thor's
backside a few times because they're
pretty cool right they're pretty capable
having said that moving on to the next
thing basically of course Thor chooses
his own path by joining the Guardians of
the Galaxy we knew that was happening at
the tail end of what was going on in
like Avengers end game and all that kind
of stuff kind of a funny thing due to
the death of Iron Man this is the role
that likely would have been assigned to
him and the comics Iron Man actually
joined the Guardians of the Galaxy for
the exact same reason Thor's joining
them now that he just had to get away he
wanted to be away from Earth and all the
crazy calamities and chaos and
everything and wanted to do his own
thing but nonetheless right so so it's
cool to see that happening of course
Peter Quill doesn't seem too happy about
all that probably because Thor is more
of a man than he is uh but then the
movie looks like it revisits the car
we're kind of guessing here because
there's a couple scenes or a scene where
it looks like it's got some artifacts
from sakhar and the environment looks
really similar but there's no guarantee
that that's the case but we did get a
whole lot of new different uh new
locations over the course of this
trailer uh one of the these comes in the
form of Thor using Stormbreaker to
travel the bifrost which is really
really awesome and one of these
locations is actually Olympia which is
the home of Zeus and of course Hera now
we it looks like we only really get to
see Zeus I love the way they saw the way
they showed him for the brief second
that we got to see him he looks very
similar to Zeus in the comics so I'm
glad it looks like they're maintaining
that appearance I really wouldn't have
cared that much if they changed it but
it's a cool little thing to see that
they're basically keeping it the same
following that of course Thor and Korg
end up finding like this giant ice
monster which I think is a monster that
was killed by Gore or probably a God
that was killed by Gore which really
really excites me to give you guys
perspective here Gore is so hardcore he
tortured the god of torture just to show
you guys what this dude is about he's on
a whole different level but this is also
a homage and not really a homage but
like it really takes from the Thor God
of Thunder storyline which was the god
butcher where you first got got Gore and
one of the things that happened in that
story was Thor didn't initially know
what was going on with Gore all that had
happened is he had stumbled across these
Slavic gods that had basically been
killed and strung up and he didn't know
what was what was happening he was like
what in the world and everywhere he went
he found these gods that had been killed
which ultimately led him to tracking
down Gore when he first encounters Gore
it's an amazing moment the fight between
the two is phenomenal we have we have
that whole series over at Comics
explained so make sure you guys go check
it out but that's why I say there's a
possibility that this may not be the
case the MCU does play by its own rules
but if that were true this would not
make any sense because literally this is
in Thor God of Thunder like it's in the
god butcher's story like there's a point
this particular monster is actually
known as faligard the Behemoth he's
called a patron god of the galactic
Frontier champion of the tournament of
Immortals for five centuries straight
and they say he wrestled black holes for
fun so I don't really know why it
wouldn't be this guy I it's a one-to-one
shot from the comics
but this whole this whole scene I think
is designed to give this idea of just
how capable Gore is that he's just
killing these massive Behemoth Gods
something else to point out is that in
the comic it was only Thor who
discovered it the fact that Korg is with
him is just obviously a byproduct movie
but around that same time is when the
shadow Monsters of the uh of uh Gore
start to attack which may or may not be
an aspect of this film like we know that
supposedly the necro sword is supposed
to be a part of this right all black is
supposed to be a part of uh Gore's I
guess Weaponry so they may very well
incorporate this in there for those of
you guys who don't know think of the the
little you know Shadow Monsters of Gore
is like those things from the Thanos had
in in Avengers end game The Name Escapes
me I came off top my head but think of
those except they're made of living
Shadow and that's basically what Gore
has uh having said that Valkyrie looks
like she has the least interesting job
ever which is to basically be a
representative for new Asgard so that
looks like it kind of sucks but kind of
awesome at the same time I mean for her
it probably sucks because she loves
battle right but she's literally stuck
at a desk job so who knows how that's
going to turn out uh we do get to see
the full Guardians of the Galaxy team
which I really really loved uh one of
the other things that I thought was
really hilarious and it looks like it's
going to be a main a main focus of the
movie is the comedic interactions
between Thor and uh and Peter Quill I
know that after Thor 3 a lot of people
weren't necessarily I wouldn't even say
a lot like the vocal minority weren't
necessarily the biggest fan of the more
comedic element of Thor I love it I love
the comedic element of Thor I love how
it really is a way to transition him
away from like you know another and I'm
super serious and I never take things
serious you know take things funny and
I've got no sense of humor or anything
like that I'm just serious 100 of the
time you know I love like them breaking
away from that and and allowing more of
like the Thor personality to shine
through in terms of having a more
comedic uh comedic element and in the
comics he's nothing like that I mean he
does have a good time he parties he does
get drunk uh but more often than not
whenever you see Thor in the comics he's
just serious and it's cool I guess for
himself doesn't have much of a
personality and the comics like if you
look at Thor by himself he doesn't
really have much of a personality what
usually makes the Thor Comics
interesting is everything else going on
around him which is why if you read a
Thor story that focuses on the nature of
Thor it usually gets boring really
really fast so I really like the idea
that they focus more on his personality
making him more comedic as opposed to
just kind of keeping him dry and
humorless and that kind of a thing
keeping him bored right you know I'm
glad they moved beyond that but uh the
last thing that we get here and this is
what I'm really really interested to see
and and honestly I think I know exactly
how this happened uh we get to see Jane
Foster as Thor using a re-assembled
Milner now I gotta say I've always loved
Jane Foster as Thor when that initially
happened if those you guys who don't
read comics when that initially happened
and Jane Foster became Thor uh people
who don't read Comics got pissed off
because they thought it was like a
permanent change to the Thor Mythos
anybody who's been reading comics for
like 10 years or better knows like Thor
was going to go back to being Thor he
was going to get his hammer back which
he did right and then of course they
actually ended up destroying the hammer
and then recreated it uh but it was a
really really cool moment I loved Jane
Foster's Thor she was phenomenal it was
it was a great story it was just a
ridiculously good story now the question
has to become how is it that the hammer
was reassembled how was the hammer put
back together okay cool so here's a few
things to understand what I would say
this largely ties into both the origin
of Jane Foster as well as what's at
least the origin of Jane Foster Thor as
well as what's recently happened in the
Thor Comics because if you go and you
read the Thor Comics right now you will
see mjolnir reassembled and it looks
exactly like it does on the trailer
except it's uh orange and it's got
orange light coming out of the cracks
instead of it being blue so when it came
to Jane Foster being Thor this all went
back to a story that was written in 2013
or so called Original Scent and
basically the original sin was a story
where you had the eyes of the Watcher
which were blasted to the world and
everybody learned everybody else's
secrets and all that kind of stuff it
was it was weird there's a fight that
happens between Thor and Nick Fury where
Nick Fury says something to Thor and
then he basically becomes unworthy he
loses the ability to lift his own Hammer
now years later we would find out that
it was actually Nick Fury referencing a
comment that that Gore had made in the
sense that Gore believed that the gods
don't care about Mortals hence the
reason why Gore went on a crusade to
kill the gods because there were just so
many conflicts where like Mortals were
killed and gods could have stepped in
and done something but they never did
and so we just developed this hatred for
for Gods as a whole when Nick Fury
basically tells Thor Gore was right then
Thor believes it right he's just like oh
my God Gore was right right you know we
as Gods we're just inherently bad but he
loses the ability to lift his own hammer
and so following that he basically
starts using yarnbjorn as his main
weapon in the aftermath of Thor
basically losing his worthiness that
somebody picks up the hammer and says
there always has to be a Thor and it's
Jane Foster right so that point going
forward Jane Foster becomes the the
person worthy of lifting a hammer and
then goes forward and does her own thing
now eventually of course like I said
Thor gets his hammer back but in a more
recent storyline that happened you ended
up learning that the reason why the
hammer is so powerful is because at some
point in the past Odin had captured what
was basically a cosmic entity and then
had it placed within a piece of uber
metal that was used to build the hammer
so the hammer quite literally housed the
power of a cosmic abstract it was that's
why it was so powerful uh but in the end
Thor has to basically fight that Cosmic
abstract and then the Hammers destroyed
in the process ultimately the hammer is
reformed but it's all fractured and
cracked just like in it is in the
trailer and that's where we stand right
now as far as mjolnir goes so I would
say that it was probably e tree played
by Peter Dinklage who reformed the
hammer of Thor and he probably did this
because at some point after Thor walks
away from being his quote-unquote
superhero self and basically becomes a
pacifist that Jane Foster is like well
somebody has to be Thor there has to be
a Thor like if you're not going to be
that person then I will be that person
and so whether it's because she contacts
etrie or somehow they come across each
other or however it is that their paths
cross and they end up meeting that each
tree ends up being the one to form Anew
to form a new hammer for Thor a new
mjolnir basically reassemble it and then
Jane Foster somehow gets her hands on it
and she ends up becoming the new Thor
now I'm ballparking here all we have to
go on is haphazard guessing a little bit
of hearsay and whatever it was that
happened in the comics we won't know
until more more stuff comes out because
it's literally a teaser right it's
basically the MCU equivalent of being
like this movie's actually happening
guys so uh so I have no clue what's
gonna come out of this but there's some
cool stuff over the course of this
teaser and I absolutely loved it so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end let me know your favorite
moments let us know if we missed
anything and I will catch you all later
peace